supposing that there were a thousand
wonka bars in the world and during the
contest you each opened a certain number
of them you would have a certain
chance of winning that number is a
probability
everyone understand yes danny tyburn
what is the probability that five white
kids found wonka's golden tickets excuse
me
what the golden tickets all five were
found by white kids
so what is the probability of that
happening wonka's an international candy
brand after all
seems highly unlikely i can't figure
that one out
but maybe if i research the demographics
of 1970s sugar producers and weighed
against global distribution maps hold on
danny
give me 15 minutes i can do this for you
the rest of you all just uh
play fortnite on your cell phones
works every time
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that takes you down a world of
pure imagination and then ruins all the
fun by adding math homework my beloved
theorists when i started doing youtube
nearly 10 years ago never dreamed that
i'd be in the position i'm in today one
channel with over 10 million subscribers
and still going strong
film theory here that's getting really
darn close to that exact same milestone
you should help us get there by the way
by subscribing a channel that was
youtube's most popular live stream for a
long time
now food theory our newest addition to
the theist family which if you haven't
checked out and subscribed you should i
mean you clicked on a video about the
math of a fictional candy company why
wouldn't you subscribe to a channel
where we talk about the math of a real
candy company we're already knee-deep in
testing a lot of interesting stuff on
gummy bears which is yielding some
pretty fascinating results for an
upcoming episode so that one's coming
down the pipeline but then there are
also episodes that are already on the
channel like how few licks it takes to
get to the center of a tootsie roll pop
or
the episode that came out today where we
come to the definitive answer on whether
a hot dog
is actually a sandwich spoiler alert the
classification of pizza
and chicken wing is also up for debate
link is right there on the top of the
description or
upper right hand corner of the screen
please please go check out that channel
if you haven't already we've been
working
really hard over the last year to make
this channel happen so please
validate our efforts by watching and
subscribing thank you but you see
that's the whole thing that's incredible
here i am beyond grateful to have people
watching
four channels worth of content at this
point but not just watching
engaging with all of those channels and
you see that's the one i want to talk
about right now because if you're the
kind of person who pitches theories to
me online you might not think that i see
them or you might think that i don't
care you might think that i'm just gonna
sit here and make theories about marvel
movies rick and morty and disney until
the day my arthritic fingers fall off
and while that
is true it's also true that i see your
ideas and i
love those ideas case in point i
recently got a tweet
from at nia not jax saying quote i want
film theory to do a video on the
probability that
five white kids would get all the golden
tickets at matpat gt
please this has bothered me for years i
gotta say neonate jacks i like your
style
willy wonka and the chocolate factory is
one of my favorite movies of all time
if you haven't seen it shame on your
parents but as the quick refresher it's
a movie about an eccentric candy factory
owner willy wonka who creates a contest
to give away his factory and plants
golden tickets in five
random candy bars to select who can come
into the factory for a behind the scenes
tour
and as nia rightly calls out all the
kids that find these tickets are well
they
they look very similar but what are the
odds
of that sort of thing happening my
knee-jerk reaction here is that this has
got to be
super low right wonka is an
international candy distributor but
there are so many complicating factors
at play from historical era to
demography to international trade
policies that well
the answer is actually far less
clear-cut and that means it is plenty
ripe for our theory today
so strap into your psychedelic theory
boat and watch your chins for any errant
candy counters cause we're heading on
one sweet ride have you ever noticed
that by the way i've watched this movie
so many times i noticed all the small
details the candyman just
clocks that girl with the counter it is
brutal in order to answer the main
question
i'm required to address another question
that doesn't exactly have itself a
straightforward answer
what defines a white person
did you just feel that it's the icy
chill of the internet breathing down my
neck watching everything i say from this
point forward in the event that i
unintentionally say something offensive
but stand down pc police i get it racial
identity is the kind
of thing that gets pretty complicated at
both the personal level since a lot of
people don't believe a single racial
label identifies them correctly but also
at the global scale even how often
racial data has been used to
discriminate
race ethnicity and skin tone don't
always match up across different
cultures or
even person-to-person but my
interpretation of that nia not jack's
tweet leads me to believe that they're
using the term white kids to refer to
people of primarily european descent who
generally have lighter skin tones i'm
largely taking that definition from a
youtuber named masamon who produces some
really interesting videos about the
history of ethnicity and demographics
around the world so if that's your thing
check out his channel it's actually
really strong long story short here i
recognize that not all people of
european descent are white and not all
white people are of european descent but
in an effort to define our data sets and
answer the question as well as possible
that's the line that we're gonna have to
go with today so getting a calculation
for the probability that all
five of wonka's golden tickets would go
to white people requires two data sets
the number of
all white people on earth and the total
number of all people
on earth technically that gives us the
probability of one golden ticket going
to a white person whoever they are and
then we raise that probability to the
fifth power since the probabilities of
different events are multiplied together
to give total probability
and before the statistics nerds come
after me yes i'm ignoring removal from
this calculation technically once the
first white person has gotten himself a
golden ticket both the population of
white people
and the population of planet earth
decrease by one but since our numbers
are already
so massive it's not going to affect
things all that much so all that being
said this should be pretty
straightforward right two numbers
boom calculate the probability multiply
it five times well that's where you'd be
wrong
you see the math is probably the easiest
part first time in the history of ever
that's been said that all is just a
bunch of simple multiplication no the
problem
is determining the world population and
percentage of white people
because that requires us to know when
the movie is taking place and that's
not entirely clear it's debatable
whether it's set at the time that the
movie came out
around 1971 or sometime after that based
on wonka's super advanced technology or
heck even a time before that because
charlie's village seems
well very rural however there is one
very small detail that answers the
question for us
after charlie finds his golden ticket
and starts to run home through a
construction site for a moment
just a moment we can actually see a
piece symbol drawn in chalk
behind him that symbol was invented as a
protest sign for nuclear disarmament in
and didn't become widely popular until
the late 1960s so it is safe to say that
the movie is set in the present day
by which i mean the present at the time
which is now the past for us
it's around 1970. all right according to
statistics compiled by the united
nations the world population in 1970 was
about
3.632 billion people less than
half of what it is now 50 years later by
the way the total
white population is a little bit harder
to calculate because a lot of countries
didn't ask about ethnicity on their
census at the time many countries still
don't to this day however demographers
have estimated the percentage of the
world's population that's been white
throughout history giving us
approximations of just over
30 percent of the world in 1950 and just
over 20 percent
in the year 2000 assuming that general
trend is correct the world's population
would have been 26.464 percent or a
little over one in four
back in the 1970s if we raise those odds
to the fifth power
we get ourselves the odds of all five
golden tickets going to white kids at a
minuscule
.13 chance
for a little perspective the white kids
sweeping the golden tickets is about
1 in 800 whereas your chances of
catching a foul ball at a professional
baseball game are about one in a
thousand
sure those odds aren't great but
unlikely things do tend to happen a lot
a lot of fly balls and golden tickets
out there in the heat
so case closed episode over time to hop
over to food theory and check out the
new episode over there
nope we are just getting started because
the calculation we just made makes a few
key assumptions the first of which is
that everyone on the planet
has access to wonka bars and that's just
not very realistic
a better calculation would consider
which markets wonka products would have
likely been excluded from in the 1970s
and to do that we need to answer one
important question
where the heck is this movie supposed to
take place charlie and his family and
willy wonka all sound american
you can move in immediately and me
absolutely what happens to the
whole family but then random townspeople
and charlie's teacher all have
themselves british accents a test we
take each friday
on what we learn during the week will
now take place on monday before we've
learned it
plus when we see the town from above it
looks like a quaint little village from
the middle of germany growing up
i always assumed that the movie took
place somewhere in europe despite most
of the main characters speaking with
american accents but the movie actually
gives us the answer
via the newscasts well we in america
slept right here in america so
strange as it might seem this movie is
set in the u.s
you could be stubborn and say that
they're watching american news
broadcasts from a foreign country but we
actually see an international broadcast
from paraguay when the south american
news covers the fake fifth winner and we
can clearly see that the television
refers to it as a satellite broadcast
so yes it is a weird heavily european
influenced version of the us but we are
apparently
somewhere in the good old u.s of a the
movie makes wonka products seem like one
of the biggest food brands in the world
so the question now becomes how
widespread would the distribution be for
a major us-based international food
business back in the 1970s sorry this is
just one of those moments do you
see how stupidly over-researched this
all is how deep we go
about questions literally no one cares
about oh sure let's research the global
distribution map of 1970s era us-based
food stuff companies to determine why
wonka so white i mean these are without
exaggeration some of my favorite
episodes but it's moments like these
where the rabbit hole has gotten
so deep and the research is just such an
obscurely specific
topic that i just really appreciate
doing this channel if you like these
sorts of episodes too
please subscribe if you haven't already
to film theory i
really really want this channel to hit
10 million subscribers and would really
appreciate your help getting there this
channel works really hard and it really
deserves it so please if you could help
that would be amazing
we can't use the real life wonka candy
brand in this case because that was only
a really solid product integration
launched in time for the movie
so it doesn't really have that much
history to go back on no if we're
looking for the most accurate
business to compare 1970s wonka to it's
the world's most famous source of excess
sugar
coca-cola based in atlanta georgia
coca-cola has been available in
different parts of the world for over a
hundred years and in 1970 coke had the
ability to stretch across the planet
just like you see with wonka candy in
the movie so that's why i chose it as
our wonka stand-in as opposed to
say another candy company like hershey
which had themselves smaller
international distribution back in the
70s
so that being said and this one's
important for our calculation there were
a lot of places that you couldn't get
coke in the 1970s the first major market
the soviet union and
for fairly obvious reasons we had a war
it was a really cold war we almost blew
each other up with nukes
several times and then we didn't yay
history
fanta a coca-cola product came to russia
in 1979
and coke a few years after that which is
still too late for our calculations
market number two that's excluded china
interestingly enough coca-cola was first
sold in china
in 1927 but after mao's communist
revolution in 1949 coca-cola and a whole
lot of other western products were
outlawed in the country and coke
couldn't come back into china until
1979 and finally market number three
the arab league nations the arab league
which consists of mainly western asian
and north african countries like egypt
iraq and saudi arabia weren't too
pleased when coca-cola opened up to
israel in 1966 and they levied a boycott
against the soda until 1979.
so for our calculations we'll be
deleting the 1970 populations of china
the ussr and the arab league nations
from our world population totals
reducing it all by 1.1
billion people it also reduces our total
white population by about 228 million
at 733 million divided by 2.457 billion
raised to the fifth power we get
ourselves the new grand total of wonka
so white
at point two four percent that is the
chance of all five golden tickets going
to white people
once you eliminate all the places that
wonka candy bars probably wouldn't be
it's um twice as likely as our first
calculation but
it is still a 1 in 400 long shot
it really just seems like there's this
astronomically small
chance that the golden tickets would
shake out this way right well when i
ask a question that way you know i'm
misleading you you you do know that
right i've
only been doing that for eight plus
years because there's one more factor
for us to consider and it's probably the
most important one of the bunch
sure we've gotten ourselves an idea of
how many people had access to wonka bars
back in the 1970s but we have to account
for how
many bars those people are going to buy
in various parts of the world because
let's face it some people
are gonna buy very very few if any bars
and some little monsters are gonna buy
a lot of bars it's all about disposable
income and relative wealth we hear that
virus assault for instance blitzes
through
760 000. sweetheart i can't push them no
harder
19 000 bars an hour they're shelling now
obviously she is an extreme
outlier still the scene in charlie's
math class shows us that his peers were
typically buying a lot of wonka bars as
well
you peter golf how many did you open 150
charlie bucket how many did you open two
200 100 200 just two
as we can see from charlie's british for
no apparent reason teacher it's not just
commonplace for these kids to buy wonka
bars by the hundreds it's expected but
not every country in the world has the
same disposable income that the u.s had
in the 1970s for instance
india had more than twice as many people
as the united states but the us's per
capita income was 45
times what india's was so if they're
buying candy at a rate consistent with
their earnings
it's actually a lot more likely that a
golden ticket would show up
in the us rather than india so by
combining per capita
income data from 1970 with populations
by region of the world in the same year
we can adjust the probability to account
for purchase power
the regions with predominantly white
populations also had themselves
very high regional wealth multipliers
north america was 44
western europe 24 australia new zealand
23.5
in contrast the multipliers for the
developing world show just how
relatively poor they were in 1970
africa's multiplier 2.7 south asia 1.8
latin america 5.3
so throwing in all of these new
considerations into our calculations
suddenly the chances for any one golden
ticket going to a white person
jump from our initial calculation of
about one and four
to now more than three and four it
triples
which means that our final final
estimate for the probability that
all five golden tickets go to white kids
is drum roll please
what do you mean we don't have a drum
roll effect we've done this bit before
we have it in our fine fine don't look
for it then just give me some dramatic
sound effect
you've got mail really
24 even if we want to adjust that number
and assume that all of the predominantly
white regions had the same percentage of
white population as the usa which was
87.7 percent
likely much lower than in northern and
western europe the final odds
still come out to over 12 so when we
consider things like excluded markets
and relative wealth it's still not
super likely that all five golden
tickets would go to white kids but it is
much
much likelier than it might initially
seem now somewhere between 12
and 24 ain't great odds but it's far
from evidence that the system was rigged
you know what
is evidence that the system was rigged
slugworth how is it possible that he
could get from charlie's hometown
somewhere in the u.s to the precise
locations in germany and
england and across the us before the
winners even had time to do a television
interview
of course we find out at the end of the
movie that slugworth has been working
with wonka the whole time so if
slugworth knows where to go
that means wonka knows where to send him
and he knew where the golden tickets
were going
they probably even set up charlie he
buys his golden ticket with a dollar he
finds in a storm drain and then just so
happens to run into slugworth between
the candy store and his house
charlie hasn't been on the news yet so
how does slugworth know that he's got
the last golden ticket
because he planted the money and he
planted the bar with the golden ticket
in it
he may have even gotten the candyman in
on it since charlie doesn't even pick
out the chocolate that had the ticket in
it
you ever noticed that one the candyman
just picks it off the shelf and hands it
to charlie
slugworth probably even gave him the
instructions hand it to a kid that's
worthy why not try a regular wonka bar
this time
and you see that's the last nail in the
coffin here what's interesting isn't the
fact that all the winners are white
it's the fact that they're all kids
because as we see throughout the movie
adults are buying these candy bars by
the millions because they have the
expendable income and yet
somehow against all probability the
winners
are five children it's because wonka
through slugworth
rigged it so kids got the tickets he
needed the five winners to be kids
who also just so happen to be white it's
something he admits to in the final
scene
i can't go on forever so who can i trust
to run the factory when i leave
not a grown-up that's why i decided a
long time ago that i had to find a child
and that's why you sent out the golden
tickets that's right so what are the
odds that all five golden tickets go to
white kids at neon jacks based on pure
probability
one in eight hundred based on a bit more
research one in four but the real
probability is one
in one because the whole thing was
rigged from the start
but hey that's just a theory
a film theory and
just a reminder to go and check out food
theory if you liked this episode which
let's face it you got to the very end of
it you did then it's important for you
to know that a lot of the research that
we got for this one was stuff we learned
while doing work over on food theory so
go check it out there are
a lot of fun episodes on the way
including how to break the colonel
sanders curse the dark
truth behind count chocula and beating
the chipotle menu so
please if you haven't yet give today's
new episode of food theory a watch and
give that
channel a subscribe links are on screen
right now and i'll see you across
all the channels next week